What do you believe is the biggest misperception that the American people have about you as a man and a candidate?
Using specific examples, can you take this opportunity to debunk that misperception and set us straight?
Thank you, and that's an opportunity for me, and I appreciate it.
In the nature of a campaign, it seems that some campaigns are focused on attacking a person...
...rather than prescribing their own future and the things they'd like to do.
In the course of that,...
...I think the president's campaign has tried to characterize me as someone who's very different than who I am.
I care about 100 percent of the American people.
I want 100 percent of the American people to have a bright and prosperous future.
I care about our kids.
I understand what it takes to make a bright and prosperous future for America again.
I spent my life in the private sector, not in government.
I'm a guy who wants to help, with the experience I have, the American people.
My passion probably flows from the fact that I believe in God.
And I believe we're all children of the same God.
I believe we have a responsibility to care for one another.
I served as a missionary for my church.
I served as a pastor in my congregation for about ten years.
I've sat across the table from people who were out of work...
...and worked with them to try and find new work or to help them through tough times.
I went to the Olympics when they were in trouble to try and get them on track.
And as governor of my state, I was able to get 100 percent of my people insured,...
...all my kids, about 98 percent of the adults.
I was able also to get our schools ranked number one in the nation,...
...so 100 percent of our kids would have a bright opportunity for a future.
I understand that I can get this country on track again.
We don't have to settle for what we're going through.
We don't have to settle for gasoline at four bucks.
We don't have to settle for unemployment at a chronically high level.
We don't have to settle for 47 million people on food stamps.
We don't have to settle for 50 percent of kids coming out of college not able to get work.
We don't have to settle for 23 million people struggling to find a good job.
If I become president, I'll get America working again.
I will get us on track to a balanced budget.
The president hasn't.
I will.
I'll make sure we can reform Medicare and Social Security to preserve them for coming generations.
The president said he would.
He didn't.
Governor.
I'll get our incomes up.
And by the way, I've done these things.
I served as governor and showed I could get them done.